[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au sommaire de ce 8 avril nous les
avions rencontrés début mars Olga et
Maria ont fui la guerre en Ukraine avec
leurs familles et sont accueillis par
une amie à Voisins-le-Bretonneux ces
deux jeunes femmes continuent tant bien
que mal leur vie elles ont aujourd'hui
toutes les deux trouvées une école une
nouvelle déléguée pour le Secours
Catholique des Yvelines Mario de Misko
vient de succéder à François Paget une
prise de fonction dans un contexte
particulier augmentation de la précarité
suite à la crise sanitaire guerre en
Ukraine elle est notre invité et puis
nos idées de sortie et d'activités pour
le week-end dans les Yvelines dans cette
émission nous vous ferons découvrir
notamment le graffiti
la guerre se poursuit en Ukraine et les
réfugiés continuent d'affluer en France
il s'agit surtout de femmes et d'enfants
plus de 9600 jeunes Ukrainiens sont
actuellement scolarisés principalement
dans les académies de Nice et de
Versailles a annoncé le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale début mars nous
étions allés à la rencontre d'une
famille
ukrainienne hébergée par Daria à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux depuis trois
semaines deux sœurs ont réussi à trouver
une école le symbole que la vie continue
malgré tout on a attendu à peu près une
semaine et c'était vraiment pas long du
tout par rapport à ce qu'on pensait et
après on était très très contente de
pouvoir reprendre les études parce que
rester à la maison on ressassait des
mauvais souvenirs ça nous déprimait je
suis très célèbre au collège tout le
monde cherche à venir me parler ou à me
demander quelque chose c'est très
touchant la plus jeune a trouvé une
place dans le collège Hélène Boucher à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux Olga elle suit
actuellement des cours à l'École des
Beaux-Arts de Versailles je suis très
contente d'être à l'école des Beaux-Arts
c'est une chance j'ai trouvé une copine
là-bas elle est japonaise elle m'aide
beaucoup elle me soutient et je trouve
que les gens me comprennent bien ils
cherchent tous à m'aider un monsieur
très gentil m'a acheté tous les
nécessaires dont j'avais besoin pour la
peinture il nous a invité dans le
magasin et il a dit choisissez tout ce
que vous voulez je vous l'achète ça me
permet de dessiner de plonger dans la
peinture et je voulais remercier ce
monsieur particulièrement Olga vient
d'une famille de peindre son
arrière-grand-père
Ivan krasni a exposé des oeuvres au
Musée national de Kiev et dans divers
musées ukrainiens
et bon elle va aussi travailler avec le
professeur de sculpture pour qu'elle
aura un éventail de
de possibilités pour s'exprimer j'ai
déjà vu que son niveau de dessin avec
excellent et la prochaine fois elle va
certainement se mettre à la peinture
j'avais besoin de m'occuper pour me
détendre et me changer les idées et la
peinture c'est pour moi quelque chose
que j'adore et qui me fait du bien outre
la scolarisation Maria et Olga ont
également trouvé une activité
extra-scolaire je suis très contente de
mettre inscrite au badminton vraiment
j'adore ça je trouve que les gens sont
très accueillants très chaleureux c'est
ce que j'adore ici
la danse c'est vraiment ma vie j'adore
danser et pour moi la danse ça me permet
d'oublier la raison pour laquelle on
s'est retrouvé ici
même si la guerre reste toujours
présente en arrière-plan les deux jeunes
filles se sentent intégrées dans leur
nouvelle activité et grâce à la mairie
de Voisins-le-Bretonneux la famille
dolga et de Maria a également trouvé une
maison au sein de la commune
le Secours Catholique qui compte dans
les Yvelines une nouvelle déléguée que
je reçois aujourd'hui dans ce 7 8
week-end c'est Mario de Misco bonjour
vous avez pris vos fonctions à la
mi-février vous avez succédé à François
Paget qui avait exercé ses fonctions
délégués entre 2013 et fin 2021 dans les
Yvelines on va parler avec vous de
l'action du Secours catholique dans les
Yvelines aussi peut-être de l'urgence
actuelle pour l'Ukraine déjà parlons de
vous comment vous abordez cette nouvelle
mission dans quel état d'esprit
heureuse de prendre ses fonctions dans
cette belle association du Secours
Catholique une belle association au
niveau national mais aussi au niveau
local dans les Yvelines c'est vrai que
le Secours Catholique est très actif et
notamment avec un très grand nombre de
bénévoles sur notre territoire
départemental puisque nous avons 2300
bénévoles qui ont travaillé
œuvrés en relation avec des personnes
qui vivent la précarité dans les
Yvelines en 2021 voilà et je suis très
touchée de
le l'engagement et de l'investissement
de ces bénévoles pour ceux qui qui en
ont besoin quel est le rôle d'un d'une
délégué justement quel va être vos
missions qu'elles vont être vos missions
alors mes missions sont vraiment de
porter le pilotage un peu général de de
nos actions dans le département en lien
avec des bénévoles en responsabilité
l'idée c'est vraiment de pouvoir
coordonner les actions dans un dans un
sens qui est le nôtre et qui est
vraiment axé sur le lien avec les
personnes et un lien très fraternel avec
ces personnes vous arrivez de la
Seine-et-Marne vous aviez plutôt exercé
du côté de l'Est francilien là on est
dans l'ouest francilien et vous avez
exercé notamment pendant plus de 10 ans
au sein de structures d'insertion part
et vers l'emploi des chantiers
d'insertion des agences d'intérim
d'insertion donc je le disais
principalement en Seine-et-Marne l'aide
pour pour les autres l'accompagnement ça
a toujours fait partie de vos créneaux
voilà c'est vraiment pour moi c'est
c'est un engagement profond
à la fois pour la relation et puis pour
construire ensemble une société plus
juste et où chacun puisse trouver sa
place
missions aujourd'hui tout à fait tout à
fait c'est vrai que vrai pour les
personnes qui vivent la précarité ça se
fait à tout niveau et en Île-de-France
on retrouve vraiment les mêmes besoins
et des problématiques qui sont
similaires entre ces différents
départements donc vous arrivez comme
délégué de ce secours catholique dans
les Yvelines avec 60 équipes locales
vous lisiez
2300 bénévoles dont on parlera dans un
instant 15000 familles sont accompagnés
et les personnes aussi isolées en
situation de précarité dans les Yvelines
justement comment sont-elles
accompagnées comment accompagnent
comment le Secours Catholique accompagne
ces personnes très important pour nous
c'est vraiment le lien la rencontre
c'est prendre le temps de la rencontre
donc qui se passe déjà sur nos accueils
localement dans nos équipes locales et
ce temps permet vraiment à chacun de
voilà de se considérer comme partie
prenante ce qui est important c'est de
prendre le temps de la relation pour que
pour donner confiance aux personnes et
d'aller vraiment vers une autonomie
aussi dans dans les choix d'action qui
vont pouvoir aider à rebondir donc dans
ce cadre là nous menons des actions
vraiment et des projets très divers sur
des chants très divers de l'alimentaire
mais aussi vers d'un accompagnement
culturel et puis en ce moment un gros
enjeu sur l'accompagnement dans toutes
les démarches numériques qui sont
vraiment qui ont vraiment explosé ces
dernières années et nous avons pu
bénéficier de l'aide financière de
France relance pour pouvoir équiper
pardon nos
équipes en matériel
et maintenant nous pouvons avoir des
accueils sur ce plan numérique où les
personnes sont là pour apprendre et
s'autonomiser sur leurs espaces en ligne
et pouvoir faire leur démarche accéder à
leurs trois de façon plus autonome par
exemple cette délégation dans un
contexte forcément particulier et une
crise sanitaire qui sait mieux aussi en
crise économique le contexte aujourd'hui
c'est une précarité qui a
malheureusement augmenté qui
a augmenté dans les Yvelines dans le
reste de la France aussi c'est une
précarité qui a augmenté et l'accueil
des Ukrainiens se fait dans les Yvelines
et le Secours Catholique vraiment est un
acteur parti prenant de la coordination
pour cet accueil tout en ayant à coeur
justement de ne pas baisser son activité
sur l'ensemble de la précarité et
l'ensemble de l'aide qui doit être
apportée aux autres personnes et
notamment les personnes migrantes qui
fuient d'autres
lieu de guerre il y a aussi ce contexte
de la guerre en Ukraine vous en avez
parlé avec plus de 4 millions de de
réfugiés Ukrainiens près de 30000 qui
sont arrivés en France c'est l'urgence
du moment mais il faut pas elle ne doit
pas éluder les autres urgences est-ce
que vous disiez exactement c'est très
important pour nos équipes de d'avoir
encore cette qualité parfaite d'accueil
de toute personne qui qui est en demande
et qui rencontre des difficultés sur sur
les Yvelines et sur cette urgence
Ukraine comment le Secours Catholique
est mobilisé ou parliez d'accueil c'est
ça alors nous sommes mobilisés déjà au
niveau départemental nous faisons
vraiment partie de des instances de
coordination autour de la préfecture
pour cet accueil et à ce premier niveau
nous sommes en capacité de réorienter
les personnes qui se présentent dans nos
accueils vers les bons interlocuteurs
pour pouvoir obtenir leurs accès aux
droits
donc la protection temporaire mais aussi
accès on a des produits de première
nécessité s'ils en ont besoin puisque
localement nous sommes en lien avec les
coordinations qui se font au niveau
municipal et donc dans ces coordinations
nous intervenons vraiment en
complémentarité avec les autres acteurs
avec les autres associations et en
fonction de ce que nous pouvons nous
proposer et nous proposons beaucoup
d'accompagnement et en particulier nous
sommes vraiment sur ce lien social déjà
ce lien à faire entre les familles parce
que parfois des familles sont hébergées
dans des logements vacants ou dans les
familles et ne se connaissent pas entre
elles donc nous pouvons créer des
espaces de liens pour qu'elle se
connaissent et créer de la solidarité
entre elles et puis nous intervenons
pour
l'initiation aux Français et
l'autonomisation dans notre ville
auxquelles des Yvelines une dernière
question nous reste une quinzaine de
secondes pour les téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent comment on peut aider
justement le Secours Catholique alors
justement le Secours Catholique national
a mis en place déjà un appel par rapport
à l'Ukraine qui est notre axe majeur au
niveau international ce sont des dons
financiers vous pouvez aller sur le site
internet du Secours Catholique voilà et
c'est donc vont déjà principalement
aujourd'hui à notre réseau puisque nous
sommes Caritas France et nous
appartenons au réseau Caritas
International et donc nous aidons les
Caritas ukrainiennes il y a deux Caritas
ukrainiennes et les Caritas qui sont
frontalières en particulier aujourd'hui
il y a une grosse campagne d'aide sur la
Caritas Pologne qui soutient les
hébergements des personnes qui se sont
déplacées d'Ukraine toute dernière chose
2300 bénévoles est-ce que vous avez des
besoins en bénévole il y a quand même
une grosse mobilisation est-ce que vous
avez besoin de bénévoles aujourd'hui
tout à fait aujourd'hui nous accueillons
avec joie de nouveaux bénévoles pour
porter ses activités nos activités
classiques mais aussi ses activités
d'accomple d'accompagnement des familles
qui arrivent sur notre département donc
pour tous les informations vous le
disiez sur sur le Secours catholique
pour savoir aussi comment aider
l'association toutes les informations
sur les sites Internet qui s'affichent
en bas de l'écran merci Mario de missco
d'être venu sur ce plateau je le
rappelle le nouvel délégué du Secours
catholique dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
cette semaine la famille de Samuel Paty
a porté plainte contre les ministères de
l'Intérieur et de l'éducation nationale
pour non assistance à personne en péril
et non n'empêchement de crime les
proches du professeur
histoire-géographie dénoncent une série
de défaillance et de Lourdes négligence
qui ont conduit à l'assassinat le 16
octobre 2020 Samuel Paty avait été
décapité par un terroriste près du
collège où il l'enseigner à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine à Élancourt
près de 600 salariés de Thalès sont
manifestés ce 5 avril mobilisé depuis
deux mois les employés demandent une
hausse de salaire de 4%. la conférence
de presse a eu lieu ce mercredi 6 avril
à Saint-Ouen la deuxième édition de la
biennale d'architecture et de paysages
d'Île-de-France se tiendra du 13 mai au
13 juillet 2022 à Versailles sur la
thématique terre et ville lors de la
dernière édition 2019 plus de 200 000
visiteurs avaient participé à cette
biennale à Montigny-le-Bretonneux du
matériel médical en partance pour
l'Ukraine une collecte spécifique opérée
par l'Association des médecins des trois
villages du matériel d'intervention avec
notamment des kits hémorragiques pour
les Sauvet ils ont pu être achetés grâce
à la générosité des médecins 3500 euros
ont pu être récoltés l'hommage à la
mi-journée de l'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à Laurent
Bouvet le politologue co-fondateur du
mouvement le printemps républicain est
décédé en décembre dernier à l'âge de 53
ans il enseignait la science politique
depuis 2011 à l'UE
[Musique]
en tractant au Raincy pour Emmanuel
Macron le Premier ministre aurait violé
la période de réserve électorale à
laquelle il est astreint or la séquence
du 24 mars n'a rien d'illégal en effet
il n'est pas interdit pour les membres
du gouvernement de faire campagne il
faut juste que le cadre juridique soit
clair alors pour rappel cette
traditionnelle période de réserve
électorale qui a débuté le 18 mars a
pour objectif de préserver la neutralité
politique de l'autorité administrative
et la parité des agents publics en
période électorale par conséquent les
membres du gouvernement les
fonctionnaires et de manière générale
les agents de l'État sont tenus dans le
cadre de leurs fonctions de s'abstenir
de participer à toute manifestation ou
cérémonie publique de nature a présenté
un caractère politique toutefois le
Conseil d'État a rappelé depuis
longtemps que les fonctionnaires ont
comme tout citoyen le droit de
participer aux élections à la campagne
et de militer mais ceci en dehors de
l'exercice de leur fonction
il est vrai également que le collecte
électoral interdit aux membres du
gouvernement d'utiliser les moyens de
l'État dans le cadre d'une campagne et
de faire de la propagande alors qu'il
s'exprime officiellement autant en tant
qu'autorité gouvernementale les
ministres restent malgré tout libre de
se déplacer en tant que personnalité
politique ainsi lorsque ces derniers
prévoient de soutenir un candidat lors
des placements doivent être programmés
pour qu'il ne puissent pas y avoir de
confusion avec leurs activités
officielles et gouvernementales
par conséquent la visite du Premier
ministre au Raincy a été clairement
identifié comme étant déplacement de
campagne non inscrits à son agenda
officiel et a été selon Matignon pris en
charge par l'équipe de campagne
d'Emmanuel Macron bref une visite dans
les règles de fait le premier ministre a
pu faire campagne pour le candidat
Macron sans contrevenir à la période de
réserve
enfin et pour Emmanuel Macron au même
titre que les autres candidats il n'est
tenu à la réserve que la veille du jour
du scrutin demain donc comme pour les
sondages ce sera silence radio
match de football international ce
vendredi à Croatie sur scène l'équipe de
France féminine U20 a été battue par la
Suède U23 en amicale le score final de
bu à zéro et des conditions difficiles
avec beaucoup de pluie face à des
Suédoises plus âgé et expérimentés une
rencontre dans le cadre de la
préparation à la Coupe du monde U20
féminine qui se déroulera du 10 au 28
août au Costa Rica les joueuses de Sonia
zirage seront fixées sur leurs
adversaires le 5 mai prochain avec le
tirage au sort des groupes alors de la
dernière édition du Mondial en 2018 en
France les Bleus avaient terminé
quatrième derrière le Japon vainqueur
l'Espagne et l'Angleterre
bonjour Aujourd'hui TV 78 vous emmène
découvrir le graffiti je suis avec deux
heures le graffeur et avant de vous
présenter on se trouve au grave parc de
Mantes-la-Ville vous connaissez bien cet
endroit alors est-ce que vous pouvez me
présenter un petit peu les lieux
qui a été inauguré de mémoire en 2008
parce que j'avais été présent pas en
tant qu'invité mais voilà en tant que
spectateur il avait inauguré toute une
fresque avec des anciens et voilà
c'était très cool donc vous êtes un
graffeur yvelin et en plus d'une passion
pour vous le graffiti c'est aussi un
vecteur de lien social exactement ça
fait 7 ans que je dispense des ateliers
d'éveil de sensibilisation à street art
dans différentes structures j'ai fait la
psychiatrie pendant 5 ans à Théophile
Roussel à Montesson j'allie le
médico-social et le graffiti et donc
aujourd'hui l'apprentissage ça vous
connaît et ça tombe bien puisque vous
allez me donner un petit cours moi qui
n'ai jamais touché de bombes de ma vie
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui est prévu
bah là je sais pas moi je vais partir
sur un du voilà c'est un peu perso mes
amis comprendront et puis ouais
exactement et en fait quand je vais de
toute façon je vais te montrer mon sac
il y a plein il y a plein les bombes
j'étais pris des Caps des skinny des
pâtes des médiums tu vas kiffer je t'ai
même pris une petite paire de gants bon
bah c'est parti alors en fait le
graffiti c'est pas compliqué ça regroupe
globalement trois styles le tag qui est
une signature tracée le flop qui est une
qui est plutôt
entre l'intermédiaire entre le tag et le
graphe donc c'est des lettres plutôt
arrondies et le graphes qui sont des
lettres en volume donc là concrètement
tu vois tu peux te dire que le Love
c'est un graphe ça c'est un flop vas-y
parfait ça c'est un flop et ça c'est un
tag
[Musique]
donc là deux heures est en train de
poser les bases du graphe et ensuite moi
je crois que je vais intervenir pour
apporter ma je crois au dessus
je t'explique qu'est-ce que je
t'explique mon petit bichette
donc la partie Nord va être en rouge OK
et la partie Sud va être en bleu
donc c'est parti alors la distance
idéale c'est à peu près 8 cm là en gros
tu vas remplir et en fait ce qu'on
appelle un remplissage électrique ça
veut dire tu remplis pas comme ça tu
remplis comme ça
si jamais comme tu commences en fait et
que tu as jamais gratté de ta vie tu
fais des traits comme ça c'est des
Accous d'accord et toi un peu il y a ça
voilà Monsieur mais ça va tu es pas
mauvais hein
c'est comme quand tu fais la cuisiner tu
t'en mets sur les doigts c'est comme ça
c'est quoi le le graphe dont tu es le
plus fier enfin des graphes que qui t'a
marqué est-ce que tu en as un ouais
Théophile Roussel on était en équipe on
était avec des vrais on hôpital
psychiatrique là quand on a fait j'ai
organisé le premier festival en
psychiatrie quand même et c'était super
sympa
[Musique]
veux-tu essayer de faire des ronds
monsieur au niveau du placement là ça
peut être pas mal ici ça peut être sur
le
couple comme ça c'est bien ça fait du
feu
ah là
monsieur ensuite tu m'as fait un petit
par la haut s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
bon ma dernière ligne n'était pas les
gars
2h on va devoir rattraper ça toujours
les gars toujours
[Musique]
on va faire un point de fuite ça met le
flow donc le point de fuite attends je
vais mettre ici tu vois donc en fait
tous les traits en fait ce qu'il y a de
plus technique tous les traits tu vois
je vais les réunir vers le point mais là
faut remplir en noir
ah
regardez-le regarde-le moi je m'occupe
plutôt du remplissage
la dernière étape je crois c'est les
finitions exactement monsieur on passe à
la dernière étape
bon voilà deux heures on a fini notre
petit graffiti enfin je dis petit au
final ça prend pas mal de place sur le
mur merci beaucoup moi je crois que j'ai
appris quelques bases il me reste encore
du travail avant de d'arriver à votre
niveau c'est que de l'expérience et que
du travail c'est rien un mais ça va tu
es pas mal c'est bien tu as capté déjà
le système D4 c'est tout de la distance
en tout cas pour découvrir le graffiti
vous pouvez vous rendre avec vos propres
vomissi c'est un espace en libre accès
pour faire pour s'entraîner essayer de
pas passer sur notre tag mais allez-y et
repassez-moi les gars c'est un terrain
c'est fait pour ça les gars il y a pas
de problème laisse ma gueule y est
[Musique]
alors ce week-end le club de Montfort
Lamaury Houdan organise sa dixième fête
des plantes et des jardins de le samedi
9 et le dimanche 10 avril de 9h30 à 18h
plus de 50 exposants seront présents
lors de cette fête des plantes ce
week-end c'est surtout passé un moment
agréable en famille
de vous évader en fait dans les
différents stands qui vous accueilleront
dans je dirais presque une réplique de
votre jardin en
en grandeur nature
[Musique]
c'est un vrai nom un événement je dirais
local qui permet d'accueillir tous les
tous les habitants du cœur d'Yvelines et
même au-delà et c'est des moments je
dirais d'échange de partage autour de la
conception du jardin autour des plantes
et
je dirais d'une façon générale autour de
la nature
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 15h le samedi et le dimanche Stéphane
Loriot vous proposera une conférence sur
les paillages et Oya pour un jardin
naturel à 16h le samedi et le dimanche
c'est Philippe Pipard qui vous attendra
à son stand avec vos orchidées pour vous
proposer en fait des trucs et des
astuces pour le rempotage de vos
orchidées et dimanche tout toute la
journée il y aura la possibilité de vous
rendre au stand de du montfortois en
transition qui vous expliquera en fait
comment faire son propre compost
[Musique]
cette année plus particulièrement nous
aiderons des familles accueillies enfin
des familles ukrainiennes accueillies
hébergées au sein de notre territoire le
coeur des Yvelines et c'est pour ça que
du coup qu'on fixe l'entrée à 3 euros
pour les adultes au dessus de 16 ans
[Musique]
Mo et note bleue c'est le nouveau
rendez-vous proposé par la commanderie
de 50 ans en Yvelines une célébration de
la créativité entre jazz et lecture pour
ce premier épisode l'écrivain est
récitant Daniel Maxime sera accompagné
du pianiste Alain Jean-Marie
représentation ce samedi 9 avril à 19h
la nouvelle saison à France Miniature
sera lancée ce samedi 9 avril le parc au
117 monuments et 25 attractions et de
retour avec une nouveauté après la
reproduction de l'univers Fort Boyard
c'est maintenant un espace de 370 m² de
jeu dédiés à l'émission Koh-Lanta qui
sera accessible aux enfants et premier
événement de la saison la traditionnelle
chasse aux œufs de Pâques les 16 17 et
18 avril et justement pour terminer
cette émission les lapins et les cloches
seront bientôt de sortie les chocolats
tomberont un peu partout dans le
département pendant le week-end prolongé
du 16 au 18 avril plus d'informations la
semaine prochaine dans le prochain 7 8
weekends bonne fin de semaine à tous et
à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]